all right we finally made it to part
three we're talking about zinc
if you have not uh seen part one part
two i put the links down below
but zinc is a very uh fascinating
mineral
and very vital to your health a lot of
people are deficient
but it also affects the prostate out of
all your tissues
the prostate has the most concentration
of zinc
of any tissue that you have and having a
deficiency of zinc
could lead to hypogonadism where you
have smaller testicles
smaller output of testosterone
because you need zinc to make
testosterone your sperm is rich
in zinc as well and also if you have an
enlarged prostate
you may have high levels of something
called dht which is a more
potent version of testosterone and
there's an enzyme that converts
testosterone to
dht it just so happens that zinc
blocks that enzyme so zinc is really
important in prostate health
testosterone health and sperm viability
all right the next thing we're talking
about is
insulin so zinc is actually stored with
insulin it's involved in the production
of insulin
it's also involved in the secretion and
storage of
insulin so if you're type 2 diabetic
it might be a good idea to make sure you
have enough
patients that uh have pancreatitis for
example are usually low in zinc
and also a condition called pancreatic
insufficiency
basically it means that the function of
the insulin is suppressed
and there's two parts to the pancreas
you have the extra
gland which is all the enzymes okay so
if you have a deficiency of the pancreas
and you're not outputting enzymes
you're going to have a hard time
breaking down your food as well as the
endocrine portion
which is involved in the insulin and
glucagon
and other hormones that are related to
blood sugars so you're going to have
lowered zinc
in both the inflammatory condition with
the pancreas
as well as just the lack of output of
enzymes and hormones
so real simple solution take zinc if you
have a pancreatic problem
all right so now we're at the immune
system
very very uh interesting that your mast
cells
the cells that are involved with
histamines and algae reactions
and asthma symptoms need zinc
as their main mineral so when you take
zinc it can act as a natural antibiotic
a natural anti-inflammatory reduce
inflammation and
mucous and zinc actually can inhibit
certain viruses as well
especially the rhinovirus of the sinuses
the superficial
internal layer that surrounds your
airways are loaded with
zinc okay of course you have all these
mast cells there waiting to
deal with any type of foreign particles
like pollen for example zinc can
decrease the time of having the common
cold
if you can take zinc right at the very
beginning of getting a cold
you can shorten the time considerably
now another interesting side note about
zinc is that
certain funguses candida
grow with these minerals and so they
will tend to steal your zinc
and other minerals like manganese and if
they take your zinc
and leave you deficient then they can
survive better because they weaken your
immune system
so there is this underlying immune
battle between your immune system
and microbes and trying to snatch up and
steal all the zinc right here
so i hope you guys now have an increased
awareness of the importance
of this really simple trace mineral in
your entire health
i always recommend taking trace minerals
in their complete
blend not just taking one trace mineral
because you need other trace minerals as
well
so find a good trace mineral that you
can take on a regular basis to
compensate for all the other
deficiencies
in your environment in your food all
right guys thanks for watching
hey guys real quick i have a new healthy
keto eating plan for you
just go to drburg.com it's right on the
front page i put a link down below
download it it's free check it out